Adam left co-host of Bleacher Report's
the left Co show Emmy award-winning
sports anchor - you got two of them -
yeah but it's not about you guys you
guys are going for like national big
time you got yours in Kentucky yeah okay
I'm also ap sportscaster of the Year
Kentucky 2013 kind of own the state for
thank you thank you you gotta take over
where you're playing man I own my court
so you you got like a statue or
something of you in Kentucky
oh I did have a Fathead in a bar that
said where's the queso coming out of my
mouth okay because right after I get off
the news I'm going inside the tin roof
kitchen making me some queso I'm telling
you man look you got I don't have one of
those now I'm jealous maybe next time
yeah I need a Fathead yeah okay so
what's the biggest story at the Final
Four uh I would say for me personally
it's a combination of the Chris beard
Bruce Pearl factor like both of those
guys we're never gonna get there and I
I've fallen in love with Bruce Pearl so
much I really just want to drink with
charles barkley if they win like that's
my entire goal this weekend but i want
chaos
i want those two teams to be in the
championship forget is oh forget
virginia i want to Texas Tech Auburn
final that's why I think the biggest
story is because everybody was looking
at this going well must-see TV of Zions
here Zions new not here Duke's not here
North Carolina's not here and I said why
not just celebrate an event that you
don't know how it's gonna end 100% like
I'm I'm fine if Texas if Texas Tech wins
greet you've been doing this for so long
you've seen it play out almost every way
yes but when there's a championship that
we don't predict at all enjoy that
that's beautiful
no no get that off nothing better than a
sporting event where you don't know
right I mean that's what we love about
it is and you have these Hollywood
directors and producers they try to
create something like this but you can't
create something that's unscripted like
I don't know like I think you could do
this like Nick Foles
in the Superbowl in that stadium behind
us you can't predict that oh by the way
Eagles Super Bowl champions sorry I had
to remind everybody that suburban Philly
guy in the house Dan yeah
no I do not you don't know what I love
the story okay I just root for stories
so somebody goes oh he has a green shirt
goes green it's like a kelly green the
19 might be more definitely not a Jets
Jersey oh did you see the new Jets
jerseys not good
you don't like no no no not a good
Jersey evaluator sometimes I say I'm
good and then everyone says yeah I
didn't like them I didn't like them kind
of looks like Marshall how would ya well
we are Marshall yeah how would you
describe the Left Kosho I would say the
left coast show now that I've traded
Sims to NBC and I've gotten you guys
back in return kind of feeling social
Walker tree I would say right now wait
are you Minnesota are you Dallas we're
the team yeah we're down any word sorry
Sims I would say right now it's really
trying to unmask NFL players and show
who they really are so we just had Pat
McAfee ran Gatland shret Brown got a few
giraffe guys coming up but this Aaron
Rodgers story is like the number one
thing in my world so you guys were
talking about it yeah it's the best
egos ripping a franchise who would you
rather interview Rogers or McCarthy I've
always wanted to interview Aaron Rodgers
because I feel like his IQ was
super-high he has a very high sense of
self and I would want to crack that code
oh you're not cracking it I know I but
that's why that's what you wanted yeah
you want to challenge yeah but he's yeah
he doesn't he avoids those questions and
giving those answers like he does
defenders I'd like his take on
psychology I'd like his take on emotion
I'd like to I wouldn't even talk
football I would get into a staring
contest for 45 seconds and just see how
he interacts with that I'm fascinated by
him he's one of the smartest
quarterbacks we've ever seen but if
you're so smart how did you let this
continue like this is all wasted at your
nerves have you ever had a boss that you
thought you were smarter than yeah right
yeah who kills you on the inside and you
his prime he's going five years six
years you're wasting me you're getting
massages like I understand why Aaron
Rodgers is going crazy but why doesn't
man
do something about because they don't
have an owner because they're the Green
Bay used to there's no Linda Thompson
Ted Thompson if you read Thai done
killed it with the story he did that
Dobson was asleep at the wheel he was
falling asleep in meetings
he wasn't signing free agents I'm gonna
draft another great no it didn't work it
says now mark Murphy's pretending to be
owner so I'm hoping it works out with
the floor I think Aaron Rodgers the
greatest quarterback we've ever seen and
I think that they've wasted him and I
hope he can come back at 34 35 what
makes him the greatest quarterback we've
ever seen he'll only have one Super Bowl
and be the greatest quarter I don't
this isn't about legacy or super I'm
looking at the ability to play the
position and I think that he can do
things that no one else has done I'm
willing to put Patrick mahomes almost
like um I will change or that sweater
Hey
I am trying to get sweater sponsorship
you need one boat is that Jackson
Pollock brand it's a Rorschach so what
do you say okay I see Aaron Rodgers I
see a man in trouble that's what I say I
do it looks like you it looks like just
chocolate syrup the show is the left go
shows on bleacher report and an
award-winning Emmy award-winning two
times it's huge in Kentucky you can't
walk anywhere and look how much time we
have give me Oh thirty Seconds perfect
okay I got to announce an award at the
national Emmys with honey there was the
same year he won like host of the year
so I'm sitting there with him and his
wife and I got the second he's saying hi
to people in the hallway he's amazing
and then he goes up there and he gave it
to stuart scott's back you know and i go
up to him afterwards I go Ernie you're
the most incredible man
and I just I just want to say that he's
amazing I want to emulate him he's the
coolest dude ever
Eastern Thank You Adam for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]